et ces trois semaines d'émeutes ont
mises en lumière la difficulté de
certains parents à exercer leur autorité
dans plusieurs communes les élus ont mis
en place des structures qui leur
permettent de retrouver leur rôle
d'éducateur auprès de leurs enfants
pas question de leur supprimer leurs
allocations la voie choisie est celle du
dialogue et de l'accompagnement
reportage à mulhouse dans la maison des
parents créé par la mairie christophe
médard virgili à dos les deux roues
quatre mille personnes vivent dans ce
quartier dit sensible de mulhouse parmi
elles aïcha cette femme d'origine
algérienne élèves quatre enfants âgés de
9 à 17 ans
comment rafa demain depuis la mort du
père les garçons sont turbulents parfois
en échec scolaire
débordée aïcha ne s'en sort plus atyak
okot pas là mais trace de ryan victoire
ccm et m'a dit nadal et des méchants ne
cote pas des fois j'arrive pas des fois
j'en ai marre vous en avez marre de coin
du tout des fois je vais aller qu on va
faire des pâtés pas faire ça va faire ça
après et sur palières l école bonjour
aïcha seront régulièrement à la maison
des parents
créé en octobre 2003 cette structure
écoute conseille et accompagne en
matière d'éducation
je vais vous proposer des gens qui
pourraient éventuellement vous
accompagner peut-être même vous
accompagnez après pour voir comment ça
ce qui est ce problème de comportement
et la kalach votre fils la demande est
importante
200 personnes ont déjà sollicité l'aide
de la maison des parents
la plupart des entretiens que nous
menons ici concerne les enfants de 11 à
18 ans voire plus dans les jeunes
majeurs dans des conduites des problèmes
de comportement de refus de l'autorité
de l'adulte d'absentéisme scolaire de
conduites addictives de fugue le maire
de mulhouse a décidé d'associer la
justice à cette action
un juge peut obliger les parents d'un
enfant difficile à suivre un stage dans
cette structure
c'est un cas une contrainte vous amène
tout de suite et tout est fait pour à
une responsabilisation des parents mais
en même temps tu tiens l'outil est en
place mais la justice tarde à s'en
servir
à ce jour elle n'a pas encore contraint
un père ou une mère d'aller à la maison
des parents